hi I'm Bob San Henry I'm talking about
the Wolfram data repository and we're
going to look at different use cases for
using the new data repository to do
analytics on data and create your own
data resources
oftentimes there's inconsistent file
formats between datasets the data is not
structured in a consistent way between
datasets are even within a data set
there's no documentation about how to
use it or examples of using it in the
worst case scenario you just have a web
page with links to another webpage with
links to another web page with links and
then eventually there's a PDF with a
graph in it and yeah how are you
supposed to do anything with that
and that's mostly a result of these
things not really being designed with
the use case of somebody ever using the
data they're designed so that some
publisher can say that they've published
their data and point people to it as
required by their funding or their
journal or whatever so we realized that
we were in a position to do it a lot
better and that's because of the cloud
and the Wolfram language so the fact
that we have a cloud means that
everything in the data repository has a
natural mechanism for distribution so
anywhere you can access the cloud which
is increasingly every Wolfram language
session anywhere you can get the data
from the derived a repository and the
Wolfram language has what we call wdf or
the Wolfram data framework which is a
standard for representing data that is
consistent and it has semantics and
real-world knowledge built into it so
it's a great way to have a have data
that's immediately computable and usable
so let's so these are sort of the pieces
of the data repository so when we talk
about the data repository we're talking
about all these things there's a website
Steven showed it in this his talk
yesterday it's been live since April it
where each each what we call resource is
the unit of the data repository as a
resource each resource has its own web
page there's a home page there's guide
page to direct you there's a search tool
and we'll see that all in a minute
another key piece is the Wolfram
language function so like I said we want
the data to be easy to get
so there's built-in symbols in the
Wolfram language now that get that data
and get metadata as well for for from
the data repository there's the back end
is all in our cloud so it's not
necessarily important for you for
anybody to know that but it's neat to
know that all of this was built using
our own technology so it's all Wolfram
language code some of its running on
your machine stone was running in our
cloud but there's not not a lick of any
any anything else so anybody with a
cloud subscription and the time and
ambition could have made this themselves
it didn't need to be us but we saw the
opportunity so we went for it and then
of course the most important part is
content no matter how great the
technology is no one's going to care
about this thing if there's not good
content so we've and the fact that we
are the company that made Wolfram Alpha
means we know a lot about data curation
and where to find data and how to how to
import it and parse it and store it so
we took advantage of that knowledge and
found great datasets and and got them in
there for lunch and then it's
consistently growing so we're somewhere
600 or so resources last time I checked
so the rest of this talk is going to be
over these use cases so sort of an
escalating set of use cases from just
sort of poking around the website to
using the data in the wulfing language
to creating your own resources and
finally to submitting those resources
for publication so we'll step through
these so we can go ahead and look at the
website this is home page you can see
there's a short description there's a
there's a search bar here where you can
search for keywords or terms that might
be in the description and then we've
divided all of the resources into along
two dimensions with a the category of
of the resource and the content type so
you can have you know astronomical data
that's that's a graph or you know
economic data that's that's an entity
store so we'll just pick one of these
randomly so here's things about medicine
and we can these are the medicine ones
are all sort of depressing we'll find a
different one let's look at economics so
here let's just pick this guy so what's
great about this so if you look at the
page for an individual resource
well this one's really small we'll find
another one to actually play with so it
has a title it has a description it's
sort of a simple short description a
more detailed description some summary
of the size and then it has this example
section which is really great because it
shows you not and it'll not only gives
you an idea of what the data actually
looks like but it shows you right away
how to use it and Wolfram language so we
have this example notebook with input
and output cells just like any notebook
and then we have this link to open it in
the cloud we can we can try that out see
how my network is doing here so so here
you go you're you're running you're
running in the cloud and you can
evaluate these things right away in the
cloud and then we have a citation so if
you want to take our data and use it in
something you're doing you can cite it
and then we have our source where we
acquired the data so we give credit
where it's due
finally down to the bottom we have
download buttons that that you know
first if you don't want to use this in
the Wolfram language you just want to
download it maybe maybe your your your
colleague doesn't have Mathematica and
isn't willing to try it you can send
them JSON or CSV or something something
more standard well we'll go ahead and
use this guy so all of these are like
the online documentation where you can
click on them and go go straight into a
notebook so so now we're moving into
that one step further were instead of
just sort of poking around as a note
here you're retrieving the data so let's
see Federal Reserve systems again that
sometimes the outputs have some
typesetting that takes a while to
display can tell that I authentically
chose a random one let's try like this
oh that's about all right um let's look
at just the first row maybe
ah here we go okay so so something about
putting all these entities are it's
slipping things up so in that case I I
was kind of grabbed one randomly and do
some some simple analysis but I'll just
use one I already figured out how to do
something good with so that we don't
waste a lot of time waiting for entities
to typeset so here's one where we have
data about weather stations so it's
looking at the frequency of rain over a
month you can see here's here's the
first five I can use take large so this
is data set so you can just take largest
as as you know the first argument
applied to the data set and it'll give
you the rain station that had the most
frequent rain in January if I'd want
just the coordinates I can do that if I
want to do this for all the months I can
grab the keys that way get it for all
the months okay so there's the
coordinates for each month let's use it
let's put them in a geo marker and use a
tooltip so we know which one is which
month that's great we got our tooltips
there and you can throw it into
Geographics
and here we have this this nice little
you know this one line of code that
grabs stuff from the data repository and
does something interesting with it so so
that's using the data but what's also
important about data repository and
resource objects in general is that they
contain metadata so when you have the
resource object so here here's what the
resource object looks like in a notebook
it has this what we call a summary blob
where you can you can look inside and
see some some metadata for you can also
access that metadata just by asking for
so these are the metadata fields that
are available some of them are less
useful than others some of them are just
sort of implementation things that are
going on behind the scenes but you can
see what categories this is so I think I
found it oh no I maybe I found in
meteorology but it could have
I've been an earth science on the
website we have the source metadata the
same thing that we saw at the bottom of
the webpage is available from the
resource object itself and you can see
this addition to the actual content of
the data being in WEF the metadata SWF -
we have entities data objects so even
the metadata is computable and then we
have content elements so there's the
default content which in this for this
case was the data set as we saw in the
last page but this this resource
actually contains four pieces of content
that if you use a second argument
resource data you can you can grab the
other ones so here column descriptions
is treated as a content of this as well
and you can see instead of just a little
Jan fab Mar you can actually get useful
descriptions for these things so that's
a sort of a example of grabbing a
resource from the web page and using it
in the language but if you want to just
work in the language itself we also have
resource search which is handy handy
function so so we have a lot of what we
call sample resources and these are
resources that are not necessarily big
historical canonical data sets from the
most prestigious literature they're
something that is useful for a certain
kind of computation or analysis we you
know it's it's nice to have this kind of
image to test this kind of image
processing function it's nice to have
data about about plant growth because
it's a good test for a certain
statistical distribution so these these
these are sort of samples so we have a
whole bunch of samples so I chose that
search and I'm gonna test randomness
again and grab one of these randomly
let's look at what it is it's so some of
these are sort of depressing I said that
I warned you about that so again we can
grab the data so and of course this is a
data set so you can do all sorts of
computation the the last presentation
here
actually showed a pretty good example of
that and I got started late so I'm not
gonna not gonna temp to do anything
interesting with that one right now
so once you've used data resources and
you want to step it up to the next use
case it's time to make your own with
your own data so so you know here I have
some I don't know if you've noticed but
I've been collecting data on everybody
here how happy they are every minute
since you've been here
and I actually have I already have that
data for the rest of the conference as
well so so so I've taken that and I've
put that into this field called content
I headed if I said this is a data
resource it has a name it has a
description and I just put that
Association in the resource object and
it had its a resource object and it work
works exactly like the resources from
the data repository once it's defined
locally its treated just like just like
the ones that are published on our
website so so this is one way to create
it programmatically but the better way
to create a data resource is with this
template notebook that we call a
definition notebook so this this was
came out in 11:1 I think this not
notebook so it has fields for all the
metadata extended metadata here
categories kind of types it would take
more time than we have here to actually
fill those out manually so what I did is
I made one already so well I did was I
went to this page about Babe Ruth
Bambino and and and I created one I
filled out one of these before and I put
it in my cloud so here's here's this
notebook that has names descriptions as
the metadata categories filled out I put
in some keywords and then we get to the
content area and just just to prove that
this works I'll paste this in again so
here what I'm using is semantic import
string in order for this to work well so
you want to give it what you expect the
type of each column to be and even then
if the data
isn't really well filled out or a
consistent this this will tend to have
issues so there's a whole art to
properly formatting your data that I
don't have time to get to but we'll talk
about resources for that in a second so
so here we have this nice data set where
we've data objects and quantity objects
and numbers and strings and proper
columns so if I just go through and
everything with this little Wolfie here
means that that Bob wants you to
evaluate it so so that's defining the
content you're defining the example
notebook that will be used
that'll be retrievable by users and it
will be used to create that web page
that we've seen so then I have this guy
well that creates a simple dollar dollar
resource object so that so that turns
this notebook into a resource object I
could copy this use it in any other
notebook it'll work just like just like
the ones in the public repository or the
one I created programmatically but once
you have the one of the point of having
a resource object is that you can put it
somewhere so you can cache it locally
you can you can but we're gonna look at
now is you can deploy it to a cloud
object so if you cloud deploy this
resource object what you get when you
visit in a browser is this nice webpage
it looks a lot like the ones in our
public data repository with a name and
description and here's your nice example
notebook rendered out all in HTML so you
can direct your colleagues here and
what's even better is that they can take
this resource object here and if their
Wolfram language users oh sorry weird
this guy go they can just use it
directly so so the fact that I set in
that notebook if you saw it said
permissions go to public so if you have
public permissions on your deployment
then your colleagues whoever you send
that cloud object to can use that
resource object directly the C word my
notebook
the last thing you want to do if you
think your resources generally
interesting and not just for you and
your colleagues is you might want to
submit it for publication and for that
you'll need a publisher ID I'm going to
talk about that in the next talk so if
you're interested in publishing stay
tuned we'll talk about have a slide in a
couple minutes about that for now I'm
just going to use use the one that I
have access to and I'm going to give a
note like this is a demo do not publish
it and that way oh sorry I'm not going
to type it so my colleagues won't get
over ambitious because I don't think I
have legal rights to the webpage that I
script so so that gives me a resource
submission object it's puts my
submission in a queue a human being will
come around and review it and it'll
prove it and it'll be published or
they'll contact me and say hey this
isn't this doesn't meet our standards
for the following reasons or this data
set just isn't really interesting enough
for us so so that's sort of a manual
process that involves humans so so that
brings up the question of what do we
want to submit what is interesting so we
want vetted data things from
publications are great we want you to
attribute it properly we want you to
tell us that you have the rights to
publish it we want you to write a nice
little description about it and then of
course it should be in wdf so she have
quantities entities it should be
semantically computable and like I said
I don't have time to show you a good
example of that but Erin Enright one of
our one of our other developers here has
made three twitch videos it's sort of a
three part segment and it's great so if
you can't wait until you stand up to see
it go ahead and scan one these QR codes
otherwise get the notebook and here's
the links or you can search twitch for
Wolfram data scraping Wolfram data
processing something like that and
you'll find Erin's three half-hour
videos and that that's the best resource
so so that's the end of the talk on data
repository if any of you
want to get to another talk what time is
it
am i okay so yeah we got five minutes if
you want to head to another talk or you
can s since it's still me we can ask
questions right up to the next talk
uh I don't have a number but it's not
insignificant
I would probably guess more than a
quarter less than half if I had to guess
you know like I said we want well vetted
sources so data.gov if you can figure
out how to get the data is a nice source
of data oh how much oh well that's the
goal is to get them to do it themselves
so far we've been doing it for them yeah
I hope I don't know I'm just a developer
I was just a developer we have we have
sales and partnerships people that that
do that any other data repository
specific things edge standard yeah so
yeah so you in order to use it you'll
want to have a cloud account but those
are free so so you need yeah do you need
you can access it in desktop or in cloud
all right some of some of these data
sets are so massive they hit a cloud
memory limit when you try to use them so
desktop is is sometimes better but ones
that aren't the really big ones worked
either place just fine and yeah so you
need a clout you need a Wolfram ID so
you can Cloud Connect but those are
frees and hopefully everybody was
convinced to do that two years ago any
other data repository specific questions
or we can move that yeah
that's a good question we have our you
know standard technical services where
you can report things where you can
report bugs and Wolfram language you
could report there as well
there's also on the webpage there's a
contact us let's see if we go here
there's a homepage there's contact us so
you can report it here as well that
might be the more direct route
yes so if you are the submitter of data
then in this in this form or in resource
submit you might have seen it here
because it's highlighted in oh no it's
not so so if here if you give it this
option of update resource and you point
that at the existing published resource
or even submission object so maybe you
have something that you've submitted and
we've said hey it's incomplete for this
reason and you want update your
submission you can use that as well
there so that update resource value yeah
and they just and they just won't have
CSV outputs we have images where instead
of things instead of those buttons
saying CSV they would have said JPEG and
PNG we have graphs where we're your only
option is to get a Wolfram language
representation right yeah so then then
your only option is going to be a
Wolfram language representation of it
because nothing else is really useful
yeah we do have this expression JSON
format which turns any expression into
valid JSON but I don't know of any place
where it's useful besides bringing it
back in the Wolfram language yes
right so I guess I'll talk about that
yesterday where seems like we're you're
adding support for RDF stuff all right
no right right I understand in there so
in order for something to us to want to
put something in the data repository it
must be useful in Wolfram language so at
the point where that is released and all
of a sudden RDF type data is very useful
in Wolfram language we would love to
have it absolutely yes right so you know
Wolfram Alpha is you know the primary
goal is to set it up for queries and
it's structured in that way whereas this
is not this is set up to retrieve
datasets whole cloth and do your own
tools on them I can call out my
colleague Alan in the back who's raising
his hand who he can go you can he's an
expert on both the Wolfram data
repository data and the Wolfram Alpha
data and can expand on that for as long
as you were willing to let him any other
or we can move on to the next talk all
right